okay so we are slowly moving forward today in this video I'm gonna teach you
about liquidity and the actual concept about liquidity so I'm pretty sure you
have watched a lot of videos on liquidity maybe on YouTube or you bought
someone else's course and you you know they taught you about liquidity so it's
my job to teach you as well because you spend a lot of money right so it's just
it's just best for me to explain what is liquidity so let's suppose that this
is resistance right and this is support level all right so we are told to sell
at the resistance and then buy at the support level okay and now you might
have noticed that I have labeled the resistance as buy side liquidity and I
have labeled the support level as sell side liquidity and I want to explain to
you why I did that but let me explain a bit more about liquidity so you can see
that price goes up to resistance and then we see a huge sell-off right so now
this area becomes a resistance because price couldn't go above that
level and there are heavy sellers around this area so price goes down and then
from this area price goes back up in like with a momentum all right so now
this place could be considered as a support level this level and this level
is now considered to be a support level so a lot of retail traders what they are
expecting is that when the price is gonna come back to this level which is
the resistance the price is gonna fall down okay so what price actually does
is let me explain to you oh sorry doo doo doo doo doo price fakes out like this
all right and then goes down all right fakes out the support level and then it
could it might either go up or down depending on the daily bias all right
so I'll assume that it just goes down so now what really happened here all
right a lot of retail traders what they do is they go short on the resistance
level and they put their stop losses right above the resistance level all
right so what price does it stops you out but then why am I calling it a
bi-side liquidity let me explain it to you very very easily all right so when
price breaks out the breakout artists people who trade breakout patterns what
they're gonna do is they're gonna buy once the resistance level is broken right
and they're gonna put their stop loss below the this level all right so they
have a buy order all right and their stop loss order is a sell order so if a
person buys if a person goes long and then he gets stopped out then that stop
order would be considered as a sell position all right so the reason why it
happens is that the so that the price can go down with a momentum with huge
volume because when the price breaks out people buy right but then they have
stop loss order so what price is it just goes down triggers a lot of stop loss
orders which are sell orders right so it's gonna create more sell orders here
and the price gonna go way down all right so people who just shorted at the
resistance level they got stopped out as well people who went long on the
breakout they got stopped out as well and as you can see price would go right
down all right this is why I call it buy side liquidity because people are
going to buy when the price breaks out of the resistance level and when the
price breaks out people are gonna buy here put their stop loss below this
this resistance level and price goes back down triggers sell orders or stop
loss orders and it just goes down similarly when price breaks through the
support level people are going to short right and when people short here they
gonna have their stop loss right here so the breakout artists they're gonna
short here put their stop loss right above the support level and what happens
price stops you out triggers buy orders okay so when we are shorting let's say
you shorted here right and price stops you out then it would trigger buy orders
because you are selling right so when you get stopped out it will trigger buy
orders and then with the momentum with liquidity price is gonna go back up with
momentum it's gonna go back to its original destination with heavy
momentum so this is the concept of liquidity now liquidity could be
literally anywhere it could be right here right this level all right when we
are in and we are in an uptrend the you can see the higher high and higher low
this high low could be considered as liquidity as well because people are
going to buy oops my bad at the breakout of this previous high so let's say
people buy here they might put their stop loss right below this previous
high low right and then in the future the price can come back down right to
some autoblock here or demand zone and then the price can just actually move
back up oops my bad it can just move back up like that so it could be anywhere
but we need to identify the most important liquidity areas so the the
more prominent that area is the more it's gonna be you know working with your
strategies the strategies that I'm gonna teach you in the upcoming videos we
are going to use liquidity we are gonna trade with liquidity liquidity is
everything all right so I hope you did understand the concept of liquidity and
I'll give you some examples in the next part of this concept